[Music]
you don't control at this shoulder
you're strong now
if we control out the elbow we use the
elbow to control same same resistance
this
if I'm here I can't I can't get it right
you can come up to your shoulder and you
can get this one and it's at the elbow
too
so I'm trying Contech atomic alright
they're strong come to the elbow can't
get it get your shoulder underneath it
and then you have a rocío variation
ultimately I'm up here boom right into
bed can't get it we want this situation
okay
can't get it stomach drop the head right
you have UPA teens you'll have your
sprawls but you don't really like this
okay
take a little more of it vouching next
time
[Music]
it's up you guys are pushing a lot
center center so I'm not trying to shove
her and make her head go down I'm
pushing through her Center every time he
goes through the center
there we're up here please you're a
little panicked aren't you relax
so you go out like this no winner here
go to the center oh no not there here
wait my basement you did leave in your
feet here you see me me me okay
[Music]
giving you back
same thing Center connection
[Music]
[Applause]
calm down you don't have arms you don't
have arms to fight with they get shot
with a tranquilizer dart you just hang
down at your sides
[Music]
push
but times you go to bed last night
hurry up what times you wake up you look
exhausted you're gonna go into combat
like that you're gonna go to on your
ship like that holy cow
let's go
[Music]
Thanks the team wants us knocking Oh
Moses so it should be easier like that's
why I was trying to do
I've tried to go here right and I'm
trying to get it EDB nugget and he's
he's falling off me do you got it like
your case is doing that he's not he's
not doing his Laura he comes up right
the response the secondary response you
got that yeah so now I got a week here
till he gets his ass up here like that
and then I can take the second home to
me it takes more effort you're burning
more ATP molecules you got it Angie wasa
especially it slow everything is fine
everything is fine though you should
take less effort everything is fine
[Music]
life's not gonna stop for you call
moving fast do it again your speeds in
your head
[Music]
so when you almost got him you go keep
guarding him and that's where you start
to lead and all that okay so we'll just
divide this to Tommy and how that
squares the basis support and your idea
of
Kazushi is you're gonna take his head
and you're gonna make it fall outside
the base of support you got that okay
when what we usually do is just get that
much angle and then we do this you see
that you guys are doing it wrong you're
trying to move this thing get that move
that
you guys not going to like it which is
probably what are you guys do it you're
in that silent agreement with UK hey
don't do things I don't like and I'll go
ahead and roll for you okay so wait up
coming here not there here
so energy OOP yeah if you're sensitive
you can see how you hold your breath
because that's not gonna work for you
you gotta get out right so you're
sensitive as a new camp as not yet you
know you got them because they're gonna
go okay so get the first part and center
that's what you're seeing why he doesn't
roll here with his shoulder you see that
he gets a little projected boom boom you
see cuz I'm not throwing shoulders now
I'm not going like this in deviation
Center deviation boom Center
and then you're going down your dishes
quick that's all that's done okay he's
much tighter
[Music]
check them out check them out check them
out do it again you're behind them James
running her backwards runner buck would
save your life jinx
save your life save your life change
that's not how we do it all you see
[Music]
get the center
yeah clear the line you're on the line
you're on the line
you're no Mary Sue okay
don't believe the hype
[Music]
so I I have let's let's make this simple
I have a no-contact let's do this I have
an indirect contact for my secondary
Kazushi the one at the bottom of the Joe
okay so that's where when I'm touching
here is all I touch and the rest of it
is a combination of the initial
attacking energy it might have any
energy and then the Kazushi energy you
do have contact ones too okay so we're
just having him here and I'll help him
balance I'm gonna put my leg behind his
and use my knee to projec you see that
so you keep getting stuck there you're
getting stuck there because you don't
have the actual staple of the heart
which is to project the energy
indirectly okay but it does happen even
on someone they get a grip or something
he regains his balance so you just come
in here you see that little me press
you can do it on that leg you can come
on the other on the other leg you see
behind and push the knee and likewise
you're here you get stuck boom right
you're gonna be able to do your let's
have me but I don't want to see you
doing this okay so I'm going i'm trying
for the projection the leg okay but you
don't sit there and wrestle for you're
not a bigger problem you know like he
said don't pull the head yes
don't pull the head but also don't sit
here and wait for life to stop and then
you're gonna do your thing okay
you're getting in the way of the bull
[Music]
you're standing behind the cape
constantly
don't bring them up to turn them we
don't want them to come up control the
wrist so the arm doesn't Bend go Crisco
break and go you didn't control the
wrist
another key home problem remember don't
pull her head down break the center
deconstruct the center
don't fall with them keep your posture
keep your ground pass you're pulling the
back foot up and you're bending over
from it keep going keep on bouncing
don't fall with them now you see you're
just leaning back foot has to be engaged
that's what's pressing
ud me start again
you're in the line don't chase 'em me
let them come back again don't turn them
just torco do not breed and bring the
arm into the torque position
[Music]
so just like anything if I'm trying to
turn it and I have this little leper
it's gonna be hard you get that stretch
down that big guy and you're gonna want
to go like this but now you're just
turning me so you can slide up the arm
as you move you see that I slide up the
arm as I move as I do the technique I
should try to keep the wrist and this
torque goes here you see that not like
that see how I'm gonna pull the chicken
wing on up this way to the more angles
you combine in an articulation the more
torque you create at the joint so this
is one plane you see that right well and
this is another plane right now I'm
going to combine the two you see then
this one here
you coming in whoop right use the in
space to let them to go in and you drop
the elbow right on the chest but you're
still in turn through the center you see
that so I'm not going backwards we're
gonna know if she's a fall on me so I'm
projecting forward then I drop with her
this is this space you see I mean it
should already be tight if you need to
finish it but you're down here
bracing okay I'm seeing a lot of crappy
versions of that one go you just got
your gun take it away
[Music]
keep playing with that it's too much
effort for this speed it's too much
effort fritzy
too much effort do your my is wrong his
weights pushing on you still this looks
like you don't train at all
walls count in this drill get on the
line again just pick her up that's why
we do jiu-jitsu we don't attack force
with force we don't contest for space
[Applause]
[Music]
you're on the line
don't pick them back up that that joke
does not go on the front or the side
you're unfamiliar with the material
[Music]
change partners I'll save you Leah
backups here
[Music]
you pulled the head down
that timings off
Shyne way to Hartford she was
[Music]
get the center don't pull the head down
go through the center Priscilla we grab
the wrist or arm if we only have the
forearm we let go of Shiho nage we don't
fall with ruk we use the ground you're
very in love with the Oise up there like
your best friend and you can't let go
that's called attachment in budeau
very good
the fire my advice to you is don't try
to counter you cuz you're not ready for
it
just stay present then you're doing the
same training you're doing G was a -
from the inside but every time you
counter and you're going against
somebody who's present guess what you're
going to be surprised you're you don't
like that because of the self attachment
you're creating a situation you don't
like do you got it but instead you can
practice self detachment in the
discipline to not counter out of fear
not counter out of pride you're
practicing self detachment and presence
and you're not wasting fifty percent of
your class time and you're not setting
up that situation where you're scared to
death or you're ill-prepared for the
landing got it you're not a victim just
taking turns as you can go
[Music]
that's a push that's a push Cinci she
countered and she pushes really far in
here right she's countering you so you
don't want to go like this now
you just work with that energy oh that's
good enough right look I can go around
it because it's here don't let me get
you see it's in the front so I'm gonna
go around it this way and you'll just
feel it you'll go here I feel it boom
I'm around it there it is again for
every time it's around it it's telling
you what to do
[Music]
again
whoa oh you feel it go round
[Music]
but for you experiencing this to the
counter experience it experience it
experience Oh Mon taneous leaves you see
now you got attached to that one so
you're like okay I didn't feel space
I'll do it you can see so what I feel it
it's like resistance okay are you
accepted no resistance
boom but then no connected Center it
will do this your body will get used to
it and then we can have it oh yeah I do
know how to do yes
[Music]
it's all broken in here connection
acceptance lock it out as you're rolling
acceptance in your mind say I welcome
this lock it out you're collapsing at
the bottom of your rope
[Music]
even when it changes except it's walk it
out your fall like this o'clock you're
standing on center centers lock forward
roll your like this
lock your Center boom center Center all
tighter
come on acceptance no you to come in try
harder
[Music]
clear the line
sprawl out
[Music]
you didn't enter enough
you're not yielding enough yields at the
beginning yield at the beginning inter
gin and young yield at the beginning you
have no yield you're not yielding that's
why your stance is getting compromised
good eye on me katate dori chase burger
go
oh you're sinners broken all this we
faulted the inside not the outside his
weekend
[Music]
bring your bass into the fight don't
stand outside and reach in you losing
the weird environmental awareness all
day long
[Music]
Neal lower your center right trying to
brace no no no no no no we're not flash
we're not gonna dance around while they
stand still but your kidneys have to be
god-awful Henry that's no excuse for you
[Music]
try to always find the center it's not
gonna be one principle for when they're
rolling forward and then a different one
if I'm pinning or if they're going
backwards or if I'm kicking it's gonna
be the same principle because the art is
based on universal principles go it's up
to you to transport them as you
transport them that's your wisdom
growing as you can't that's your
ignorant staying
[Music]
okay you go in right and if I lose you
this is where I sit okay
the lab center
[Music]
the last center
a lot of signs are you can see that
amount of force you're taking just leave
you be
are you not attacking it just leave your
be
let's do I mean range in your name I'll
collapse enter all this connection here
[Music]
the lab Center you see that you just
look you literally went which looks
doable but I'm not really throwing you
you see but when I come in here and I
really project your body's not gonna
like it
boom like a forward pull see how you
didn't go here because his feet are
connected to Center through his Center
and I'm touching him through his Center
and so projects he was out
okay so I could go really hard and he
will never get more compressed on his
phone
okay